BELL.COM WE WILL CHECK THE
STORM ALL WEEK AS IT'S MOVING UP
THE EAST COAST.
WE TURN TO SOME BIG
BREAKING NEWS JUST NOW FROM THE
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES, DEVIN NUNES
FOLLOWED A LAWSUIT FUSION GPS
OVER RACKETEERING CLAIMS.
THAT IS HAPPENING A SHORT TIME
AGO AND I REMEMBER DURING HIS
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY,
ROBERT MUELLER OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL SAID HE WASN'T FAMILIAR
WITH FUSION SHEET HE HAS SO WE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT JEANNIE RAY WAS
ONCE HILLARY CLINTON'S ATTORNEY
AND YET SHE WAS ON HIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL STAFF.
JUST TO REMIND YOU.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE FIRM
THAT PRODUCED THE STEEL
REPORTING, THE NAME OF THE FIRM
THAT PRODUCED THAT WAS
FUSION GPS, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
>> IT'S NOT A TRICK QUESTION.
FUSION GPS.
>> NO, THAT WOULD NOT BE A TRICK
QUESTION BUT YOU NEEDED TO KNOW
THAT AND EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE
FREE WORLD THAT IS FOLLOWING
THIS CASE KNEW THE FACTS.
EVERYONE KNOWS FUSION GPS WAS
THE POLITICAL STRATEGIST FIRM
PAID FOR BY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
TO DIG UP DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
GPS WITH SPIKE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND THAT
MONEY FROM THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
WAS FUNNELED THROUGH THE
CAMPAIGN, THROUGH A LAW FIRM AS
A LEGAL EXPENSE WHICH IT WAS NOT
AND STILL PRODUCE THE NEVER
VERIFIED.
NOW WE KNOW UNVERIFIABLE LYING,
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
AND AS WE TELL YOU THE REST IS
HISTORY.
ACCORDING TO CONGRESSMAN NUNEZ,
FUSION GPS TRIED TO IMPEDE AND
DERAIL HIS INVESTIGATION INTO
THE DIRTY DOSSIER AND COMING UP
TONIGHT EXCLUSIVELY RIGHT HERE
CONGRESSMAN NUNEZ, HE WILL BE
HERE WITH MORE OF THE EXCLUSIVE
DETAILS IN THIS BREAKING STORY.
WE TURN TO ANOTHER BOMBSHELL
DEVELOPMENT FIRST AS A LAWSUIT
HAS JUST BEEN FILED BY THE ACLJ
ABOUT ISSUES SURROUNDING
MR. SUPER PATRIOT HIMSELF
JIM COMEY.
THE ACLJ LAWSUIT SEEKING
DOCUMENTS AROUND COMEY EFFORTS
TO LITERALLY PLANT SPIES
STARTING AFTER THE INAUGURATION
INSIDE THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE TO
MONITOR THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
FOR COMEY AND REPORT BACK TO
HIM.
THAT WOULD BE THE SAME JIM COMEY
WHO INFAMOUSLY SAID WE DON'T
SPY, BUT YET HE SIGNED THREE OF
THE FOUR OR FIVE APPLICATIONS TO
SPY ON CARTER PAGE AND OF
COURSE, THAT BEING A BACKDOOR
INTO ALL THINGS CANDIDATE
TRUMP, PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP AND
THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE NOW KNOW JAMES COMEY IS AN
ABSOLUTE LIAR AND LIED TO A FISA
COURT FROM A PREMEDITATED AND
WARNED IN ADVANCE.
IT WAS AN UNFAIR APPLY IT --
UNVERIFIABLE DOSSIER WITH THE
BULK OF APPLICATION USED ON THE
APPLICATION.
ALL THREE THAT HE SIGNED.
WE NOTE -- WE KNOW HE LIKED TO
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP AND AFTER
HE SPENT THE FIRST FISA COURT,
THE DOSSIER WAS SALACIOUS BUT
UNVERIFIED.
BUT HE SIGNED OFF ON THE
APPLICATION THREE SEPARATE TIMES
BOTH BEFORE AND AFTER TELLING
THE PRESIDENT THAT IT'S NOT
VERIFIED AND WHEN HE SIGNED
THOSE APPLICATIONS, HE WAS
WEARING THEY WERE VERIFIED.
REMEMBER, McCABE SAID NO
DOSSIER, NO FISA WARRANT.
THIS NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT
TAKES THE ACTIONS OF JAME --
JIM COMEY TO A NEW LEVEL OF
DUPLICITOUS LYING AND THE BIG
QUESTION IS WHY DIRECTOR RAY OF
THE FBI NOT WORKING HARD TO
CLEAN UP HIS FBI, OUR FBI COME I
HAVE AN FBI PIN RIGHT HERE
DIRECTOR RAY IF YOU ARE
WATCHING.
THIS HAS PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN THE WORLD.
WHY IS THE FBI UNDER DIRECTOR
RATE REFUSING TO COOPERATE WITH
A SIMPLE FREEDOM OF INFORMATION
ACT REQUEST?
TONIGHT THE ACLJ ARE DEMANDING
RIGHTFULLY ANSWERS AND THIS
COMES AS TWO SEPARATE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO DEEP STATES
BUYING AND THIGHS'S BEFORE